actually I think it's better being older
and having a kid I appreciate it more
hmm yeah babies are awesome they are
pretty awesome they're awesome yeah I
mean also I I've spent a lot of time on
AI in neural nets and so you can sort of
see then kind of the brain develop which
is you know what an annual neural net is
trying to simulate what a brain does
basically and you can sort of see the it
learning very quickly I think I think
possessions kind of weigh you down then
they're kind of an attack vector
you know you'll say hey billionaire you
got all this stuff like well donor stuff
now it's more you gonna do attack vector
meaning like people were targeted yeah
mmm interesting yeah like I have a bunch
of houses but I don't spend a lot of
time in most of them and that doesn't
seem like a good use of assets like
somebody could probably be enjoying
those houses and get better you Susan
than me you know I started having like
some privacy issues where like people
were like let's people just come to my
house and you know start climbing over
the walls and stuff I don't like man for
sure in recent like you wrote yours
billionaire has become a purge are you
like it's in a pejorative like it's like
that's a bad thing which I mean I think
dump doesn't make a lot lot of sense in
most cases if you if you're done if you
basically organize the company like kind
of how does this wealth arise it's if
you organize people in a in a better way
to produce products and services that
are better than what existed before and
you have some ownership in that company
then that that essentially gives you the
right to allocate more capital so it is
it's that there's a conflation of
consumption and capital allocation III
do think there in the in the United
States especially there's an over
allocation of talent in finance and law
basically too many smart people go
finance and law so you know this is both
a compliment and a criticism we should
have I think fewer people during law and
your people are doing finance and more
people making stuff and and you know
manufacturing used to be highly valued
in in the United States and these days
it's not it's it's often looked down
upon which i think is wrong it doesn't
really make sense for me to spend time
designing and building a house and I'd
be real you know get it like OCD on the
little details and the design and or
should I be allocating that time to
getting us to Mars I should probably do
the latter so you know like what's more
important Mars or a house I like Mars
okay that it could in principle fix
almost anything that is wrong with the
brain and it could restore limb
functionality so if you've got an
interface into the motor cortex and then
an implant that's say that's like a
microcontroller in your muscle groups
you could then create a neural shunt
that restores somebody who is a
quadriplegic to full functionality like
they can walk around be normal whoa
we're already partly a partly a cyborg
or an AI some buyout essentially it's
just that the data rate to the
electronics is slow it's specially
output like you're just going with your
thumbs
what's your data rate maybe
optimistically a hundred bits per second
that's being generous and now the
computer can can't communicate it like
you know hundred 100 terabytes I mean
ultimately if you if you want to go with
full AI symbiosis you'll probably want
to do something like that
I'm not sure what would happen to
language but you could probably say it
with in a situation like this that you
would be able to just if we like the
matrix you want to speak it of language
no problem
right that's why it was to download the
program but yeah I mean you could save
state and restore that state into a
biological being if you if you
wanted to in the future I'm principal
there's like nothing like from a physics
standpoint that prevents us recall
everything but just like it's a movie
critic including all the entire sensory
experience emotions everything
everything everything and play it back
right now here's the thing you are a
brain an event than that fat is your
skull yes and everything you see feel
hear and what everything all your senses
our electrical signals everything
everything so you can think about this
as being like that the computer the AI
is it's like a third layer of tertiary
layer so that is like that could be
symbiotic with the cortex it we much
smarter than the cortex but you
essentially have three layers and you
actually have that right now your phone
is capable of things and your computer
is capable things that your brain is
definitely not
you know storing terabytes of
information perfectly doing incredible
calculations that you know we couldn't
even come close to doing that you have
that with your computer it's just like I
said the data rate is slow your the
connection is weak and yet here's
another sort of interesting idea which
is because you say like where did
consciousness arise well assuming you
believe the belief in physics which
appears to be true then you know we the
universe started off as basically quarks
and leptons and it quickly became
hydrogen and helium lithium like
basically elements the periodic table
like mostly hydrogen basically and then
over a long period of time 13.8 billion
years later that hydrogen became
sentient well I hope consciousness
propagates into the future and gets more
more sophisticated and complex and and
that it understands the questions to ask
about the universe at these sort of like
the the mean sphere there's there's not
enough isolation between countries or
regions it's like if you get up if
there's a mind virus that that my
enviros cannot infect too much of the
world you know like I actually
so some ties with the anti-globalization
people because it's like man we don't
ever want to everywhere it'll be the
same for sure and and then we we need
some kind of like mind viral immunity
what are we gonna be like when 2025
years from now what are we gonna be well
assuming civilization is still around
it's looking fragile right now I might I
think the the the the mortality rate is
is much less than what is then what say
the World Health Organization said it
was it's very much much less it's like
probably at least order of magnitude
less you can look at the mortality
statistics you know by age and whether
they have comorbidities like do they
have like basically existing conditions
you know if you're below 60 and and have
no serious health issues the probability
of death is extremely low it's not zero
but it's extremely low most of the
hospitals in the United States right now
have empty or in some cases there are 30
percent capacity
I'm objectively the mortality is as much
lower like at least a factor of 10 maybe
a factor of 50 lower than initially
thought so let's close clear up the data
clear up the data there will be some
amount of lining here no matter what
hopefully more purpose of lighting up
and less yeah looks like kind of like a
practice run for something that had that
that had a potential that might in the
future have a serious like a really high
mortality rate and and we kind of got to
go through this without without it being
something that kills you know vast
numbers of young healthy people yeah in
general I think that's like we should be
concerned about anything that's a
massive infringement on our so beloved
civil liberties yes you know so it's
like you got to put a lot of weight on
that a lot of people died too you know
when independence with the country and
fight for the democracy that we have and
we should treasure that and not and not
give up our liberties too easily
I think we've we probably did that
actually fundamentally a violation of
the Constitution yeah freedom of
assembly and yeah these were these were
definitely not stand up
you know if the Supreme Court here I
mean it's obviously a complete violation
right yeah yeah yeah we're way too
simple the Civil Liberties fit in this
picture you know yeah and what what what
can the government make you do what can
they make you not do and what you know
what's what's okay
right yeah you can't take it personally
a little cooler like you know actually
no you you know like yeah it's just like
you know so it's like if you're if
you're fighting a war and there's like
some opposing soldier that that shoots
it shoots at you it's not like I hate
you
they don't even know you right yeah yeah
so just think of it like that like that
fire and bullets or whatever but then oh
you're so done take personally like what
he thinks the the best source of just
like information out there that's a good
question you know like I let's say you
just like average citizens trying to
just get the facts you know figure out
what's going on like you know how to
live your life and you know just looking
for what's going on in the world that
it's hard to find something that isn't
yeah that's that that's good yeah no but
you know I'm not trying to push some
partisan angle not trying to not sort of
an Excel IV reporting and and just aim
it for the most number of clicks and
trying to maximize ad dollars and that
kind of thing yeah you just trying to
figure out what's going on it's like I'm
hard pressed to where do you go yeah I
think like maybe just trying to find
individual reporters that you think are
good and yeah kind of falling damn has
pushed the publication
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]